thank you VAR we are here with uh Chris
flower CEO and managing director of JC
flowers and Company Chris first of all
welcome to the show Welcome uh to
Bucharest what are your first
impressions of this tournament so far
what a show you know how fantastic how
glamorous it's great to be here you're
an avid chess player yourself as well
you've played some of the greatest chess
players on the planet in fact tell us
about your Beginnings in the Chess World
how did you discover chess oh I've been
playing chess all my life I should be
better than I am I have a lot of
explaining to do what would you say are
some of the attributes that you've taken
from your chess experience and apply
them to the business world
discipline foresight time management I
wish I could do all those better
now in 2015 you also joined the board of
directors of the Casper of Chess
Foundation now the Casper of Chess
Foundation finds discovers and nurtures
the best talents in the world how proud
are you very proud indeed in the Casper
chess Foundation does fantastic work for
chess and in general for kids and for
the world
now final question tell us a bit about
this tournament once again we have
dingly run the newly crowned world
champion what is your estimation of his
powers you know I was thinking about
this I wish they could all win you have
such fantastic chess players out there
you know uh and they're they're all
tremendous so
um
and very hard to pick and I have to say
uh I've seen you play in the same team
with Fabiano caruana in London a few
years uh back how did that partnership
uh go did you help him succeed he he did
great
and and mostly because of you I have to
say I don't think I added much to it he
wasn't too interested in my ideas Chris
always a pleasure to have you on the
show thank you very much for joining us
guys thank you